Establish a bicycle-like company in San Francisco
As if you were climbing a hill and looking up to the top
Then reach them and feel happy to reach your goal
But moments later you catch your breath
Then look forward to see another slope you have to overcome
I would like to say that I founded the company in the fifth grade
But that is not true
The reason for establishing the company is to diagnose my condition at that age
I learned that I had learning difficulties
I spent many years struggling to learn at school
At high school in Chicago I met a teacher
Miss Whitefield was patient with me and wanted to help me
She was willing to spend time with me if she needed it
My mother talked to her weekly
Remind was not there at the time
Hi
how are you?
I was very happy to see you
Me too
I have not met you in a long time
I came up with the idea of ​​strengthening the abilities of teachers similar to Miss "Whitefield"
To become more effective
They make a difference in the education system
Remind is a much easier application
Continue teachers with students and parents
Using any device
So I was spending my time talking to
Hundreds of teachers throughout the country
While David was busy studying programming
Learning programming is one of the hardest
Things I've done in my life
We were two little brothers from Chicago
We did not know how to set up a company
But we started working until we founded Remind
We received financial support from our parents and some
Our close friends
I was pleased that the two brothers
They were working together on a project that excited him
We were talking to all the teachers
And when I felt their enthusiasm
I felt we were on the right track
We decided to move to Silicon Valley
A short time later, well-known investors began
In investing their money in our company
Investments were supporting us because people
Feel the value of what we offer
Children forget everything
So the application helps me on
Communicate with my students
And their families and make sure everyone
They understand my observations
We translated this part yesterday.
A fascinating story is an encouraging story
About one of my students, a "Jason"
He was unable to accomplish the tasks on time
One day, he came to tell me something
Then I promised her that I was
I will do all the homework and pass the test successfully
Provided you give us a party
When other children learned about it
They were communicating using the Remind application
I was constantly receiving messages from Miss "Limer"
It is my other classmates
For my encouragement and support
After Jason fulfilled his promise, the condition was fulfilled and the students had an ice cream party
Remind helped me motivate students like "Jason"
My bikes were similar to some students
Distinguished guests at Miss "Limer"
This proves that you can do what you want
If appropriate effort is made
The highest goal when establishing and developing a company
Is to provide what is useful and important to individuals.
Of the wonderful features in technology
The possibility of creating an application and continuing to develop it
Google Play gives us access to millions
Users we could not reach
If this application platform is not present
The application currently employs more than 23 million teachers and students
And a partner in more than 90% of primary and secondary schools
We believe that the best way to improve the educational system
Is to help build relationships between teachers and students
And parents.
And because we are a company that makes it easier
We are thrilled.